diaby trop puisque vous partez en voyage
les singles et voilà l'album duquel ce
single est extrait ce soir vient d'
incroyable on la pas et ça pour moi
c'est le la définition de la classe
voilà tous les jours cette place la
chanson c'est d'abord la chanson qui est
magnifique et toujours changeante en
1935 chanson c'est une chanson 230 à une
chanson de jeu de jean - ny ai chanté
par jean sablon unis alors qu'est ce qui
a changé entre la version de l'époque et
la version d'aujourd'hui puisque là dans
le clip qu'on vient de voir c'est vous
qui commencez alors que dans l'extrait
que j'aime pas cessé ou jean sablon qui
comme en bas parce que mireille était
quelqu un espèce de lutins très très
fantasque plein d'humour et c'est vrai
je trouvais que ça correspondait mieux à
jacques aussi d'être la personne qui
s'envoient émois amoureux transi qui
restent sur le quai mais il n'a pas été
satisfait à 100% puisqu'il a tenu à ce
qu'on refasse cette chanson pour son
propre album qui n'est pas encore prêt
et où c'est lui qui reste sur le quai et
moi de revoir un peu dû céder là
au canada c'est pas monsieur cas du suma
jamais sur ces gars-là injurieux
alors si une entreprise familiale il ya
le duo avec jacques dutronc que votre
mari il ya votre fils qui joue les
guitares les photos de l'album ont été
faites par votre premier amour jean
marie périer oui enfin bon c'est pas
comme ça pour toutes les chansons il ya
beaucoup de reprises qui sont très bien
d'ailleurs on va en parler mais pourquoi
vous trouvez qu'il ya un manque de
talent dans l'écriture des chansons ce
moment vous mais c'est vrai que au
moment où je devais m'attaquer à la
conception à la préparation de cet album
j'avais certaines chansons inédites et
donc il m'en fallait d'autres et les
mélodies que j'ai reçus ne se plierait
pas vraiment et et donc je me suis dis
plutôt que plutôt que de s'acharner sur
des mélodies qui n'en valent peut-être
pas la peine
il vaut mieux aller vers le patrimoine
et je ne savais pas que au même moment
des tas d'autres chanteurs chanteuses
non seulement en france mais aussi en
angleterre j'ai compagnie ou par tous
avaient la même idée alors là vous êtes
très en forme vous êtes très très très
gai et tout ça
l'album est pas terrible c'est presque
fait très plaisir l'album est pas
terriblement guerre mais jamais jamais
mardi les belles mélodies ne sont pas
guéris alors justement vous avez six
mois une belle mélodie blier
c'est vrai qu'ils jouent bien
alors justement françoise hardy a repris
une phrase célèbre pour parler de son
album vous dit pas les chants désespérés
sont les plus beaux sait de qui je vais
vous dire je connais là je connais
parfaitement cette cette citation ou
fait mais je vais vous citer la formule
de prêt vert s'est lassé les chants
désespérés sont les chants et plus beau
j'en connais des mortels qui sont le pur
sanglots et jacques prévert a écrit dans
paroles ou dans l'histoire les chats
désespérés sont les chats du pied bot
alfred de musset on continue
qui a dit qu en ligne qui a dit l'humour
est la politesse du désespoir
c'est le capitaine igloo non c'est un
capitaine non c'est pour les bons dans
les trucs comme ça françoise littérature
les archives crédit pour la politesse du
désespoir l'humour est la politesse
surya bonaly en 82 n'ont appelé un
double axel aux chances du muc a dit ça
est bien ici aujourd'hui savoir qui elle
dit vous pouvez détruire tout ce qu'il
vous plaira elle n'aura qu'à ou this
cabré à la bravo belle mère joan baez
utilisez google alors que l'été après
alors je vais citer la phrase en entier
parce qu'elle est très belle 1 vous
pouvez détruire tout ce qu'il vous
plaira elle n'aura qu'à ouvrir l'espace
de ces lois pour tout reconstruire
sinon je suis désolé est ce que je te
permettent de dire que c'est aussi
beaucoup c'est qu'il ya des chanteurs
qui écrivent des textes de la
littérature française je pense qu'après
hors saison et une trêve à l'ific
chanson au sujet des mélodies au sujet
des textes et là je suis tout à fait
d'accord et ce qu'elle dit il ya de très
très belles chansons qui sont de pur
chef-d'oeuvre au niveau du texte
oui ça c'est la vérité et moi je vais
vous dire ma parole ces paroles
d'évangile les paroles de ses chansons
de léo ferré sont des chefs-d'oeuvre
bien sûr chef-d'oeuvre davantage de
daniel prévost c'est qu'ils donnent du
contenu à l'émirat la ça c'est
formidable coup vous l'a plombé plus
tard
tu es là pour ça daniel moi ça m'a
beaucoup plu l'histoire de mon ami
l'arbre ce que vous chantiez je suis
désolé de vous dire peut-être que ça
vous plaît pas mais c'est une très très
jolie chanson et vous l'avez très bien
chanter maintenant donnez moi de
l'argent je continue
alors vous avez déclaré jose a redit ce
qui est passé ne reviendra plus une
phrase telle non mais une phrase non tu
très forte en laponie scène en attendant
il ya un truc terrible à dire que pour
vous qui avez incarné comme vous êtes la
génération qui a incarné l'adolescence
quand on lit des phrases comme ça qui
permet pas d'en avoir le même âge vous
dites il ne me reste plus que 30 fois à
voir fleurir les lille c'est vrai que
quand on compte la vie en année on voit
fleurir les lilas ou autre chose
c'est ridicule quand même 100 fois avoir
bondi pas jusqu'à 100 ans et cent fois
voir fleurir les nassériens et c'est
vous qui plombe l émission vient la
pandémie en faire plus et dans les
oreilles j'emploie de très bonne qualité
je vous fait sortir aux arcs beaucoup
travaillé sur vous françoise hardy j'ai
réfléchi pourquoi vous êtes un peu comme
on dit l'âme en peine j'ai trouvé trois
raisons la première raison on va pas
s'étendre là dessus on est capricorne
tous les deux si vous êtes capricorne
êtes saturnienne 1 1
il est capable moi je fais ça tu reviens
moi je connais pas les capricornes ne
sont pas saturés ags non d'accord vous
êtes anxieux angoissés vous êtes ermite
face à ces traits capricorne bien vous
vivez dans un bunker il paraît
maintenant un 16ème arrondissement et
laurence françoise hardy quand on lui
parle des meilleures vacances qu'elle
pourrait passer elle dit ses seuls à
paris au mois d'août
foisy oui c'est vrai ou alors seul dans
corse enfermé dans ma chambre avec 40
bouquin un grand plaisir lire au lit
voilà qui relie non non non non oui oui
non mais c'est pour ça que j'ai pas
besoin de voyager aux premières raisons
de votre âge un voyage par l'estrie
saturnienne deuxième raison votre grand
mère
c'est vrai que votre mère vous a pas
aidés et françoise non mais bien entendu
il est bronzé au dernier degré mais nous
sommes tous vous savez oui ma grand-mère
était à une poitrine énorme et elle
avait des jambes très courte et donc
elle a passé son temps à me dire que
j'étais affreuse devient gwalarn et
c'est pour ça que je n'ai pas imiter
j'ai arrêté au développement de ça
on disait qu'elle avait un gros ventre
c'est pas un truc génial c'est qu'elle
vous disait elle nous parlait toujours
des mecs avec une espèce de thon c'en
est un peu hystérique votre grand-mère
faire des choses général en parlant des
mecs elle vous paraît sûr de la chose la
chose est alors je me suis une chanson
de vous que j'adore qui s'appelle swing
au pressing
vous dites mon mari m'a fait la chose
aujourd'hui c'est honteux
comment est-ce que jonas michel gabriel
yared les gens les artistes de cette
trempe ont pu se [ __ ] de moi deux sets
ça mon mari ma fille c'est magnifique
cette chanson je l'aimé pas je suis prêt
si vous n'aimez pas c'est un monument de
la chanson france annonce est vrai nom
sous connaissais pas je voulais dire moi
alors ça y est le seul couple gay qui
durerait aussi longtemps finalement
médias
comment ça se fait à votre avis je pense
que c'est parce qu'on est terriblement
casanier on déteste la nouveauté les
champs nouveaux ça
est-ce que c'est pas parce que non mais
sérieusement est-ce que c'est pas parce
que dès le départ
sérieusement parce que j'essaye de
trouver le bonheur comme tout le monde
on va en parler avec eux mais dans une
certaine paix
j'essaie justement le marche et je me
dis que dutronc vous a imposé un petit
peu la même chose c'est-à-dire que
hilali passion d'existence nous avons
marre et on attend dans notre couple
ça marche très bien mais vous marchez
tout le temps au dj de voir pourquoi mon
couple marche mon marché tout le temps
monsieur prévost je suis marié seul
est ce que le est-ce que c'est pas ça
excuse sérieusement est-ce que le fait
qu'il ait ni tout de suite des distances
est-ce que c'est pas ça qui a préservé
votre bien sûr que c'est une recette qui
marche pour pour certaines personnes
mais bien sûr que le couple est une
affaire condamné plus ou moins à
l'avancé que la façon de le faire durer
le plus longtemps possible c'est de ne
pas être dans une promiscuité trop
importante ou pas trop focaliser violon
c'est sûr mais c'est des lapalissades
aussi bon non non les gens qui
attendaient les gens les gens et des
pinces sur quoi il basait le couple il
ya des couples qui sont frères et soeurs
il y en a d'autres qui sont amants
maîtresse en a d'autres qui son père
mais tout dépend sur quoi ces bases et
si on négocier si c'est basé sur sur le
désir c'est sûr que il faut éviter la
promiscuité voilà avons misé ensemble
vous et vous avez vécu ensemble ou
vision un peu mais je peux vous dire
comment vous avez vécu dit on va
demander à chacun votre voilà ils ont
chacun un état tellement d'accord on va
abandonner on va avoir donné votre coupe
je suis désolé parce que je pense qu'il
ya plein vischer zh il ya plein de
choses que vous pouvez pas votre exemple
à prendre des jeunes coup vous êtes
aujourd'hui par plusieurs générations
je suis content et j'espère que nous
érigeons à une stagnation en tournée
notamment mais vous avez su préserver
votre amour et ça dure depuis longtemps
je vous en donne un mois a su préserver
un rôti de bons parents
autant pour moi